- I'm Kristen Dicerbo,
the chief learning
officer at Khan Academy.
These are my five learning
science-backed tips
to remember what you studied.
The key is to link it to
something you already know.
Number one, make a to learn list.
After reviewing your
materials, put them away
and make a list of all the
concepts you wanna learn.
Number two, explain each
concept to yourself.
Review what you understand in
as much detail as possible.
Number three, check what you missed.
Return to the lesson and
see if there's anything
you got wrong or forgot.
Number four, relate to other concepts.
For each new concept
ask how is this similar
to something I already know.
How is it different?
Number five, relate it
to your own experience.
Ask does this relate to
an experience I've had?
How?
Reviewing and relating information
to what you already know
helps store it in your long-term memory.
Read the blog post below for
more learning science tips.